est un vrai héros donc on va vous faire
une interview anti héros alors meego est
ce que vous avez déjà renvoyé une fille
chez elle parce que finalement n'était
pas assez jolie j'ai
je pense que tous les filles sont jolies
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait un enfant
à une femme sans le reconnaître je crois
pas est-ce que vous avez déjà lâché les
chiens sur quelqu'un plutôt que d'y
aller vous même excuse et déjà fait
semblant de ne pas entendre quand
quelqu'un vous traitez de petites
[ __ ] des sondages pas de problème
avec ça
est-ce que vous avez déjà exigé un
cascadeur pour des scènes sans danger
des scènes de sexe par exemple je peux
vous dire que toutes les cascades
je suis dans les cieux et valence et
vigo lui-même qui disent à tourner
est-ce que vous avez déjà demandé les
techniciens de sortir du plateau quand
vous allez vous mettre tout nu non je
crois pas est-ce que vous avez déjà
promis à votre maîtresse que vous alliez
quitter votre femme en sachant que vous
le sauriez pas vincent cassel qui est
effondré de parler assez de mes choses
privées
vraiment est ce que vous êtes déjà piqué
la femme d'un de vos potes belge
c'est moins grave si c'est un bug c'est
vrai est ce que vous êtes déjà barré
avant qu'une de vos conquêtes ne se
réveillent jamais il est bien
c'est un vrai héros menteur on a
vraiment à coeur mais est-ce que vous
avez déjà essayé de maquiller un bouton
non et vous quand j'étais petit oui
j'avais 14 ans j'avais vu la clé et je
m'étais du clearasil et ses théories
parce que évidemment quand on met du
clae résine sur un bouton on voit plus
que ça bernard monsieur mal mandat
monsieur il n'a jamais eu d'année
sa réputation est ce que vous avez déjà
serré la main de quelqu'un en sachant
qu'il vous détestez pas complètement
est-ce que vous avez déjà laissé payer
une femme au restaurant oui
ouais est-ce que vous avez déjà citer un
auteur en laissant croire que c'était de
vous non jusqu'au quoi est-ce que vous
avez déjà dit à une fille que c'était la
femme de votre vie
pour faire plus vite l'amour avec elle
il est honnête je trouve ce type
formidable il dit la vérité il est
honnête il est extraordinaire voilà
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait virer un
acteur sur un tournage
non j'ai pas ce pouvoir si je l'avais je
n'utiliserai pas ouais est ce que vous
êtes déjà repris un cadeau à une de vos
ex
est-ce que vous avez déjà couché avec
une fille qui avait beaucoup trop bu
bigot et remember peut-être commentaire
ouais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu